peace be unto you salaam alaikum I like
we said I want to live with a cast a
greeting of all the prophets not much
isn't it yesterday and we worship the
One God just like Jesus worshiped
Abraham Noah we worshipped that one guy
we don't wish on the son of the moon the
crater of man and woman the one got
isn't it yes and he sent the last and
final revelation of mankind the Quran
verbatim word of god is that right we
have it in his original tambor free
tamper-proof la yes and everything that
we're deducing out you you also a
professor at the fix online university
and you've also taught around the world
and you deal with a lot of these
marriage issues on a regular basis yes
sir and so now we really want to stress
and as I open the show doing it God's
Way doing it because the society here
we've had the previous revelation the
previous book been changed by man so
it's hard to deduce the divine guidance
but we have the book that's been
preserved so we can deduce it right
qualified individuals like yourself
saying and that's what we want we don't
want to guess work and do it you know
according to what we think is right
because we could be wrong or right we
want to do it god's way we humbly want
to submit if this is the blueprint is
verified stamp of approval from God we
want to do it that way rather than how
Joe Schmo or mode think that is the
right way it's interesting to note when
we talk about marriage I the thing that
I always see every day is that when
there is a problem you can easily solve
the problem if in the beginning the
marriage contract was clearly understood
everybody knew what they were getting
into from the beginning then when we get
towards the end of saying talking about
divorce it's interesting again to note
that the Sahaba had a high rate of
divorce you know there was divorced the
divorce count or census what you weren't
saying was high amongst the Sahaba but
there was not a sick society what's the
difference the difference is just like
you said they divorced according to the
Sun and they were together in kindness
they let go and kindness when they were
children involved those children went
with their parents meaning if it was the
woman got remarried she the children
with the father and the woman didn't
find an excuse to say well she can't
have them why cuz I'm man
they won't say they're mad him so he's
not good enough for the child well we
understand that a young lady doesn't
think the husband is good enough or they
wouldn't be divorced in the first place
but he has a right to those children
when she gets divorced and then you find
a woman don't wanna a lot of women i
should say don't want to hold to that
principle or that rule or they want to
find every excuse in the book not to
give the man his rights in that regard
okay and then they complain if the man
doesn't provide for them which a man has
not does not have a right to spend on a
woman that does not fulfill the
obligations that she has we call this
new shoes and that that's a whole
different issue as well the point is
that all these issues should be done
instead of in front of a qualified
person the marriage itself should be
performed by a qualified with the [ __ ]
there or at olive oil or an imam or
share however want to use the term or an
alum that ship that's the one I should
perform the marriage and not any you
know Becca's a dilemma which we say any
Tom Dick or Harry amongst the Muslims
likewise divorce it shouldn't take place
at home with the husband husband gets
mad I did was put it put it put it you
know you divorced your divorce to
divorce and then you know no one knows
she's divorced she doesn't know if she's
coming or going no the divorce should
take place with a qualified individual
and these things should be stated going
back if we were talking about polygyny
earlier or how to get married the first
thing we have a lot of young people call
or they write me letters and say how do
I get married if I don't know the
brother I don't I get married if I don't
know the system you never know the
individual until you're married to them
if you do then you're having a fake
marriage the girlfriend boyfriend thing
is like play marriage has ever heard you
say a couple times have a play marriage
you're doing everything what's the
marriage then and that's why the high
rate of zinner you know it's taking
place in the society because they have
these little fake marriages okay so how
does a person get married in Islam first
of all if it's a young man or young lady
you have to convince your parents if
you're living at home that you are ready
for marriage if you cannot in you know
impress the fact that you're mature
enough to the people that know you the
best then you
should not be seeking to get married
because these are the people that know
you the best now if your parents are
saying well when we find this situation
my mother and father only want me to
marry somebody from my you know people
my race and I'm interested or my tribe
and I'm interested in someone who's from
another tribe you know this issue
parents have to start becoming wiser in
their decision making your children are
not you their culture is not your
culture the American culture well
hamdulillah has overridden all other
countries cultures when you bring them
here and that's not a bad thing in and
of itself it's a bad thing if that
American culture itself is bad it's not
seeks to do the same thing override all
cultures and destroy this nationalistic
mindset so I'll hum desirable out of me
we should to learn an example from the
concept of being an American it's not a
color what's an American just like we
say what's a Muslim it's every type of
color and that's it be the thing that
you focus on whether that person that
your child wants to get married to is
actually a Muslim following this one I
suggest two men if you want to marry a
young lady you go tell your father and
then you get your father to come in and
represent you a lot of time say the
woman has to have a Wally but we notice
also that the Prophet saws I love when
he got married to Khadijah he went and
got a best to represent him and he had
for himself hey Wally someone to
represent him so I always suggest for
the man to go get a wily for himself as
well as the lady and let these adults
these older people not your man that's
your little homie you know but someone
who has some some position in your life
to intercede on your own behalf and talk
to the other family and though more
people involved in the marriage getting
the contract together the stronger the
marriage is going to be likewise if
someone a man now he wants to get a
second wife this becomes a big issue a
man wants a second wife he has a wife he
wants to get enough on or a third one
you're about to meet a man who has four
wives and they'll all say they're one
big happy family and now one family is
crusading in court to make their more
the merrier lifestyle a legal one and so
far they're winning
lots of men come and say do I have to
tell my wife that i'm getting another
wife yes you cannot have secret
marriages the profits on our solemn said
that we announce the marriages there is
no boyfriend and girlfriend we announce
the marriage there is no boyfriend and
girlfriend no kalila you know secret
love affairs so how is this done though
but they say the Prophet didn't announce
it to his wives in that matter what the
prophets are salam didn't had he had an
understanding with his wives so what we
have to do when you want to get another
wife you have to sit your wife down and
say listen wife alhamdulillah I believe
that you're a Good Wife because a lot of
women believe you get a second wife
because she's broken or some sorts now
believe you're a Good Wife however I
would like to get another wife I don't
have another wife you do this before you
want before you find another sister you
go to yourself you find yourself with
your wife do say hey I would like to get
another wife you know in fact why don't
we do this you know it takes some time
to discuss it you know how to actually
do this but the first thing you should
do is sit his wife down and explain to
her that he's once to get another wife
but he doesn't have one right now he
wants her to understand that if she
understands that she doesn't have to
agree and he doesn't have to convince
her he just has to let her know this is
where he's at and if he leaves it alone
like that then by nature that the
situation will adjust to his favor okay
she will say I don't like it he would
say I understand that I'm just telling
you where I'm at and then that time go
so so we covered in early we got to take
a break but again for the people that
watched the part one tues episode this
is the legacy of the prophets of god
this is something that is to protect
society and again to give that man that
right if he needs to do it he does it
because there's no boyfriend and
girlfriend it's la there's no test
driving going here going there this is
to give another woman that right and you
see a lot of men dying in wars you see a
lot of you know these are just some of
the wisdom is not particularly for that
but if somebody from you know who's
never heard this before and then they're
like this this might seem very bizarre
or very you know well I don't see how
people can say it's bizarre you know
because you know if people can be
homosexuals and they say well he's
that way is he's a homosexual here's a
man saying he's desiring another man or
woman saying she's desiring another
woman and this is acceptable than
natural but for a man to be that much of
a man that he desires and once more than
one wife is bizarre no I think that what
has happened is this we're in a
modern-day mecca where every religion is
it loud abou allowed except for Islam
and they have all these idols at the
Kaaba back in those days and now we have
any religion you can say that you smoke
you know dope and ask your religion and
that's its oh that's so cute but when it
says that no Islam is my religion and
I'm Superman I want to have more than
one wife or I'm that much of a man if
you'd like you know then that's bizarre
I I find done for that but you do see a
lot of politicians presidents where they
end up committing adultery right and uh
break eminences even look what I'm in a
tiger woods happen another guy on TV the
other TV host I have let you down I have
let down my fans I love my wife with all
my heart I'm a man just like everybody
else embarrassed and ashamed for
committing adultery
indeed I did have a relationship with
Miss Lewinsky that was not appropriate
to the secret stop talking about the
cheating he cheated on you well he's a
man okay he's having affair with another
man's wife yes you know and then what
happens is the governors and like you
said he they pull these ladies in from
Venezuela and they say that she's a
domestic servant what she really is is a
slave girl for him yeah you know this is
the modern terminology for a slave girl
is a domestic servant and he gets caught
having intercourse with this lady and
this is totally understandable because
this is the nature that a law created
men with desire for women or even Hugh
Hefner it's okay he's got his three
girlfriends they got a reality show
about him and that's okay cool but he's
not giving them their rights as wives
right now when the man steps up and does
it God's Way and lets his wife know yeah
and does it put it in a hiding spot and
he's not sneaking around this is my wife
he may put some shade on it cuz you know
not gonna throw it in lady's face but
this is my wife and he handles his
business legally with both of them then
that's seen as bizarre she's got her own
apartment they're not he's got she's
they have their own apartments the home
bill women should not be forced to live
together unless some calamity happen
some people think this is like some you
know they're innocent you know so no
it's not a menage tois another and these
types of that you know snow porno type
situations that rather it this is the
type of thing is not acceptable in its
land whether each woman is treated with
respect the woman has her own place and
he/she the other lady has her own place
now let's say the man is poor the man is
bored that he shouldn't seek to get
marriage if he cannot afford to provide
for them let's say he has a place for
them and he loses his job then his
situation is the same as any man who has
one wife and he loses his job he doesn't
have to divorce his wives because he
lost his job you may have to downsize
and that becomes a challenge of life as
it is with any other married people you
know k so we get to see a lot of the
wisdom behind us but the main thing is
it's something lawful with God and it's
something that the Creator the heavens
in the earth something that allah loves
the fact that uh cyl the fundamental
with marriage is to us allah says meth
now we're through laughs I went back two
three or four well in hip to
and let Daddy Lou for what he done so
then if you're afraid that you couldn't
be just and this is just it's in time
then only marry one so when we find them
to sharia in law when there is a stated
way meth not two three or four and then
a condition then the one that's
conditional that's the exception and the
fundamental is the first thing that
there's no conditions so with marriage
the fundamental and a lot of people hate
to hear that they hate to hear that but
the reality is the reality the
fundamental what marriage is plural
marriage and the way we see that this is
the better thing is as we stated the
prophet of Allah even if we can't say we
don't say every prophet but majority of
the prophets had more than one wife
right but we also noticed that the last
prophet who was the end of salalah
related salam the end of all the
prophets and that last example for
mankind had more than one wife and this
was not something specific for him but
his best companions also have more than
one wife so we find that that is the
best situation that is the better
situation and one wife is due to a
condition there has to be a static
condition that you are unable to be just
in your time or socially you can't set
it up that way there's a reason why you
can't do it okay but really if the women
knew polygyny is the better situation it
allows them the more freedom it gives
them more honor to do what they want to
keep some in a lifestyle that is that is
real honorable they have more time to
spend with their family women by nature
or not as outward as men and forget the
terminology that there is but the men
are go out and they speak with people
not that women don't but by nature they
have more shyness than men so sometimes
if you come introverted to turn women
are more introverted than men so a man's
coming and going you got one wife a busy
person like yourself you come in and you
inundate this lady with all the things
you need her to do she has no time for
herself she has no time for herself but
if you give her some affairs and then
you go to the next house and you take
care of some affairs over there now she
has some time for her own recreation
recreation some time for herself to be
by herself clean herself and get ready
to do something else go visit her
friends visit her mother and do some of
those things that the woman we see the
West woman thinks that she has but she's
running around like with a head chopped
off now this woman she gets to take a
break she doesn't have to cook every day
now she can go get some some other
education and spend time bettering
herself what woman went what time like
that and still have her man to protect
her and then she still when she wants
somebody to babysit her children she has
her co-wife over there there's someone
she knows it's in the fam to trust and
protect her children so it's a beautiful
situation when dealt with properly but
what happens a lot of time trauma and
drama which leads to divorce and the
breakdown in a family from within their
has that is because again the the
purpose for the marriage is to have
tranquility peace and and if we live
amongst ourselves like that and make
that our point then we wouldn't have so
many problems because when these
traumatic situations happen in the
families where's the woman gets so bent
out of shape and normally that happens
because of polygyny I mean we have to
say the polygyny word you know real low
you know nobody throw anything at its
orb stage no but that's the thing you
know a lot of times the ladies don't
want to accept the fact that a man can
have more than one wife and this is not
just something in Islam it comes in
Judaism and Christianity because lack of
guidance they just have a guma if the
Italian you know their their their
girlfriend on the side or you mr. Jones
he has a girl down the block and they
know about it and they pretend they
don't recognize it but in Judaism and
Islam and you know all the other types
of isms types of waves lives they have
something similar where the Chinese they
have there was it concubine yeah they're
slave girls and these types of things to
China want some in the Chinese Chinese
culture they have that but Islam yeah it
makes it clear you have a wife yeah you
have another 10 girl friends no girl no
mistresses well there's no honor in that
yeah you know there was a survey done in
England not too long ago where they ask
you does they have a lot of primera of
post-marital sets out there meaning
relate
ships there where the guys married and
he goes outside the marriage and saying
likewise the ones man she goes outside
the marriage that happened so much so
they have whole neighborhoods where
these ladies are living and they're not
the wife day of the mistress so they
asked them would you rather be a second
wife or a co wife than to be the
mistress and ninety percent of these
ladies were talking about they'd rather
be a a co wife a second wife and have
honor and their reasons were remarkable
not necessarily for themselves they said
they said for their children their
children now are growing up as bastards
they can't have their father's name they
don't get to spend the same quality time
with their fathers because they're not
legally their children and they have to
hide the relationship so they see
there's no honor and being the mistress
the baby mama syndrome and this type of
thing like that so when this time it
really makes it clear marry the lady and
have this thing and it's so bad then a
law would not have attained it you know
this becomes an issue too because a lot
of ladies say you know I can't take it
what do you mean you can't take a now
you can live with long lesson in levels
aha Allah has not made anything lawful
or permissible that is a harm or
hardship on the society in fact polygyny
is more for the ladies than it is for
the men because there are more ladies on
the planet than there are men and if you
just go by the concept will just one
lady one man then it'd be a number of
women that didn't have any spouses not
only that Allah says in the Quran
regional in esco push are watching me
and he said ok hope is ooh you naughty
messy propecia karate min and he said
meaning Allah has made the beautiful
adorned the love of the desire for women
so not only do men like women they love
that have that desire for women it's
something that is it a lot made them so
if Allah created them this way then it's
not there's not something that's Haram
it's not something that's harm at all in
fact it's an order to keep the society
safe so we find that a lot of ladies
find a problem with this and it's okay
not to like something you can say well
you know what is lawful but I don't want
it for myself ok it may be a hardship
how
this is usually something that makes the
women go overboard and commit sins and
want to make a traumatic situation now
I'm telling yourself and all the
brothers around the world you know that
the purpose of marriage is tranquility
and that if we would draw the line and
say okay when there is no peace then we
have to stop because Allah says that
that we have to live with them in
kindness and let them go in kindness as
well so when all this this this trauma
starts coming then I think that it's
incorrect for the men to allow the
situation to prevail you know because
now you cause harm on the other family
the new wife that's coming in and now
and you have an obligation to that wife
to make sure that she's kept safe and
that you don't bring the trauma that you
have in one family into the next and
that's what you usually find that the
woman gets so depressed and so jealous
that someone that you're actually
finding tranquility outside of her
auspices and she's not going to give it
to you right that she wants to take the
drama from her house over to the next
lady's house so that she likewise cannot
have any good thing and good times and
she wants to share whatever bad
qualities you have with that other lady
so you think he's so great but he's like
this he's like that in order to bring
down the the man in the sight of his
family this type of interaction is what
causes you know dysfunctionality as some
of the early my show us that if mama is
not in tune with Papa and Papas not in
tune with NSYNC with with with Mama
actually it says if the mother is not in
sync with the father and the father is
not providing for the daily needs of the
mother we're talking about the physical
needs of the mother then what will you
have except for dysfunctional child how
can you have a same child in an insane
environment you know and so it's very
important that the men and the women
learn what their roles are and how to
control themselves purpose with
marriages tranquility well that's what
these hay allah upon want allah tells us
that they are Lee bass from Levin
interminable event
vennela basilicum they are they are a
cover a clothing for you and you are
cloaking and clothing for them what are
your clothing do recover you protect you
they cover your private areas your
defects to keep you warm in the
wintertime right you wear different ones
when it's hot as different ones when
it's raining their protection from you
if you have a family you're married to a
woman and she's not and you don't you
don't you don't put on clothes that are
ripped up in raggedy hey you don't want
to wear them you don't go out like that
if you're not covering your private
areas meaning they're not concealing
your business your business is all out
on the street you know and in everybody
the community noses that what's going on
with you and your family then that's a
problem if it's not you know concealing
your privates meaning helping you lower
your gaze you know because now you go
and you find peace you walk in the house
in the reason why the a las palmas allah
is telling us the tranquility because a
man is supposed to be outside in the
dunya just like the clothes when you go
outside it helps you from the outer
weather right and keeps your body safe
so likewise you're outside you're seeing
all these women you're dealing with this
dunya you don't want to come to a house
that's crazy so one of the things for
tranquility tranquility is a big word
but indirect means cleanliness the house
has to be clean under it means that when
you walk announce your children a
well-kept so you feel that it's worth it
I went out there fight in this dunya
dealing with all this quarter and I come
back home and my children are not clean
my house is dirty my wife is not
beautified herself and I just saw this
this this woman out in the street she's
a kafir but she's beautiful and she's
adorned herself and I come in what's
competing with that it's just natural
and I'm not saying that the brothers
shouldn't do something stay in shape we
say that because he shouldn't be able
bitney also coming two houses belly is
like he's nine months pregnant you know
this is just as disgusting as vote for
the lady that just let yourself go and
I'm not saying that women don't
sometimes gain weight when they get
older they're having our children we
can't complain about that however there
is a nature of keeping themselves up we
know that being fat and out of shape is
not something that's natural for the
human because one of the signs of the
last day the prophet saw my son said one
of the signs of the last day is that
people be city
we'll be going to rise so that we know
that this is not something that's normal
this is something that's the one of the
signs of the last day of people no
longer taking care of themselves and so
this when a man comes in his house the
prophets and I saw them said after taqwa
of Allah the best thing you could have
the best commodity in the whole world is
a righteous wife and then he swept when
you see how you're pleased with her so
you coming house she's doing her thing
it doesn't necessarily mean that she's
the most gorgeous world movie the world
but she's clean and she's beautified
your house is clean and it's beautify
your children are clean and they're
beautified she meets you with a nice
manner and she allows you through a
consideration to come out the from the
cold and being the ogre or the bear and
wind down and we have an example of that
in the story of whom silane whose son
died when her husband was out as she
beautified herself so beautiful he would
more than he had ever seen it before
when he came in so may instead of beauty
and she made such a nice meal from and
then they had intercourse and then
afterwards she said she told him a nice
way that your son had died so he was
totally satiated from being outside on a
journey and this has to be taken into
consideration and a prophet said about
it I don't know any bad thing about
insane showing it this is the way it's
supposed to be in the family of course
the condition is the matter has to be
providing for the woman and we're you
know this subject can go many different
angle we're almost out of time we just
we will start to wrap it up and we're
gonna have to continue on to do another
episode because it's such a vast topic
we're going to talk about you know
keeping the marriage together and we
started to talk about another element of
Islam that you know the man is allowed
to go ahead if because there's obviously
following the legacy of the prophets
many of them had several why Abraham all
of them except for 87 to Miriam so they
are the majority of the prophets head
and ones that we know about had more
these were the best of humanity right
yeah so this is something where the man
is obliged to take care of his
responsibilities there's no as they say
getting around so you need to take care
of your business and take this wife on
as a responsibility
it's a big responsibility isn't it it is
a big responsibility is not for everyone
i'm not saying that everyone should go
out run out and get a new wife or a
second wife or a third wife i'm not
saying that but it's part of our society
yeah it's not a point that can be
ignored yeah and it is something that is
one of the major shy away things and we
could talk about how that should be done
yeah so we'll get into so we covered
that no girlfriends no boyfriends in
Islam is marriage married or something
so sacred being kind to the wife and the
wife reciprocating and giving the
husband that right that he has that he's
a leader of the house that he's the one
that God Almighty put in charge so he's
driving the ship steering the car she's
the co-pilot yes she is she is the
coupon yeah so they're working together
as a team it should be yeah and at least
when they go here if we can wrap it up I
think because there's so much to talk
about as I said earlier knowing the Dean
knowing the divine guidance that was
sent from the crater the heavens and
earth is lon de todo complete submission
to the one guy knowing your rights and
rolls so then at the end you don't play
the guess work game like we'll do it
like this we'll do it like that
everything is not deduce from the
verbatim word of god or the temptation
of the last final see this is why the
emerged contract is very important in
the beginning and everyone from a flat
man knowledge precedes words and deeds
right at the beginning of that contract
I've found that the most people that are
involved in a contract then the better
the contract is you know like you said
people have to come learn and we want to
sweat you know you know I want to do
provide the opportunity for people to
come learn you have a website also yes I
this woman's law woman's only lower
class you can find it at my fics org
fiks org and it's for those people who
really want to learn it can't be done in
a 30 minute sitcom okay you have to sit
down you know 30 minutes a day you know
and apt and bye-bye you'll learn your
rights and you'll know your obligations
it'll become part and parcel of your
life let's continue on talking about
this topic when we come back and
inshallah we'll have you back so we can
someone in your collages label some of
my god almighty a lot of words there
does that look at ya you're about to
meet a man who has four wives and
they'll all say they're one big happy
family and now one family is crusading
in court
to make their more the merrier lifestyle
a legal one and so far they're winning
one husband 4 wives 17 children I
believe in living this lifestyle we know
them as reality TV stars on the hit show
sister wives I wouldn't want anything
else but now Hollywood's most famous
polygamists have taken on a new unlikely
role as legal Crusaders embroiled in a
courtroom fight over the fate of
polygamy are you prepared to take this
all the way to the Supreme Court if you
have to absolutely it was really an
issue of freedom of expression freedom
of love anybody should be able to
organize their family according to how
they choose and they won the first
American polygamy ruling in more than
130 years a federal judge siding with
them in December declaring a key part of
Utah's polygamy law unconstitutional
Kody Brown can openly live with his
wives just as long as there is only one
marriage license and kody is only
legally married to meri Brown the others
are his spiritual wives back here on the
D show would shake a boot oboe and you
deal with a lot of different marital
discourses and we went from the
beginning really trying to keep families
together the husband being kind to the
wife and the wife also given the husband
his rights and they both living
according to the divine system that God
Almighty sent which is Islam Tampa fee
tamper proof and then the divorce if the
divorce happens we went off we talked
about polygyny also we didn't really get
to talk about divorce but you have to
you might have to do another show for
that we talked about polygyny and no
boyfriend and girlfriend Islam doing it
the lawful way according to God's ways
that you take on another woman and you
give her rights you treat her kindly
she's not a concubine or slave or a
girlfriend or mistress she's a woman
that you cared for and you take care of
and the first wife now might feel a
little bit like you went over her and
that she's not good enough for more
she's broken down or you
no what other things do you hear that
are totally not true well the first
thing that is that is that is that when
a man wants to since we went off into
this topic we won on this you know maybe
we can stay on this for loop for the
remaining time and it should a woman
feel like she's now disrespected because
it is that she's put down stepped on no
you know I'll have the light of Valletta
mean a woman should not feel at all that
polygyny is a disrespect to her you know
allah subhana what she has to remember
allah ordained polygyny so doesn't mean
every man has to do it but if a man
chooses to do it is not a disrespect to
the woman at all Allah would not order
something that would disrespect a woman
a lot of women feel that they're
something they did if you're a good
woman your husband's going to want
another wife if you're a poor woman a
bad adapt your husband's definitely
gonna want another wiser they just
something natural zhu yin le Nez
yahawashi mean Aneesa Allah says that he
has created in mankind the love and
desire and the in his beautify for man
women everything about a woman attracts
a man and you don't multi-billion dollar
industry the porn industry as a Muslim
you cannot and you cannot be watching
porn you can't be doing any of these
things that men are wife supposed to be
doing those things for you that's it the
wife the way this is really stressed
because someone from outside again might
be looking at this like something that
is just something totally like it's
because they're inundated with things
that are cooked for they have a plastic
society that substitutes reality with
you know like you said pouring out this
is things image as opposed to a reality
you know polygyny what it is is for the
health of the society not for the
detriment of the society is to uplift
the women and to take care of them you
know we have so many women out here who
are depressed who need someone to take
care of them and not only that it's not
just for the women the men the men
themselves enjoy the company of women
and have to do it in a lawful fashion in
and out of unlawful fashion but it's no
disrespect to the the first wife but I
would say this it's definitely not for
the first ones to disrespect the next
wife because after they're married there
is no first second wife there just is
wise yeah this there's no I'm number one
I'm be
one on kabira use avira no there's no
big one little you know they're all both
your wives and husband has to treat them
fairly jealousy how does the one deal
with the jealousy is overwhelming
hamdullah the jealousies the wives of
the Prophet we're jealous when we read
the stories of the wives of the Prophet
when they even argued i would suggest
for men never get into you eyes
arguments if they start arguing hey take
your children move them out the way so
they don't have to be exposed to that
and the woman should be wise enough not
to expose their children to these types
of drama okay because this is from a
part of her being a covering for a
husband but the husband should not get
involved as we don't see the prophet got
involved with the arguments of the wives
that he had but the woman knew where to
stop don't start cursing don't start
doing these type of things jealousy is
natural however there has to be a limit
to it just like a man's desire for women
is natural but he has to have a limit
meaning he shouldn't go out there and
have more than one wife I'm sorry um
have premarital I'm a pre-med what am I
talking about ultra marital relations
she'd have a girlfriend because he
desires another woman you know he should
get married within that the context of
Islam likewise a woman can be jealous
but her jealousy shouldn't make a go
knock the other ladies door down or
curse at the lady or throw fits and and
traumatize the home environment so there
has to be just like she wants him to not
what does she want she wanted to go out
didn't have you know girlfriend is that
what the solution is well does she want
him to say no suppress that desire that
Allah gave you know either one of her
statements is wrong his desire to have
another wife is a natural one if it
fulfills it in an honest legal marriage
Islamically legal marriage then that's
okay if he does it outside of that then
that's wrong you know and I wish women
would just think about that if they want
their husband is show restraint they
have to show some type of restraint
however the husband shouldn't be
sneaking he should go to the woman first
if i'ma say I believe in having another
wife and if I get a chance I'm gonna do
it not do it and then tell him tell her
that and then say hey I'm not going to
tell you when I get married I'm just
telling you now that I want another wife
and weather prophet did it if he got
married he got married
tell you afterwards and then let her get
used to that idea before he just runs
out and gets married you know and and
having a wife involved in the process
may not be the best thing everybody has
to go about the affairs their own cells
but the more people involved men
involved in indy would mean from her
sided family in his fight then there
should be some kick man as well I
shouldn't say the more people involved
it has to be some cover the Prophet
selects Adam said go about your affairs
with some cover so you shouldn't go
announce it all I'm talking on marrying
his sister and then it doesn't work your
wife here and her feelings are hurt I'm
think about Meredith says your wife
hears it doesn't work out her feelings
are hurt again oh you try to marry
everybody in the city no your wife
shouldn't find out until you're married
so that it doesn't ruin it the prophets
allah salam said that when you find
somebody that you like and they like you
you get married if you don't you're
going to cause fitna and mischief so you
shouldn't expose your wife to every
woman that you think you're going to
marry especially since it doesn't always
work out yeah and you want to get
somebody good that's going to work for
you and your whole family not some young
lady or old lady that's going to come
into the family and think that your wife
is broken oh I'm here because you
because you ain't doing some know you're
here because you're my husband once your
nation gonna be their conversation if
the women focus on their wives their
husbands and their household they have
nothing to do with the next lady has
nothing whatsoever and the men should
stop explaining and trying to explain
why they want to get another wife just
like we can't understand why a woman
wants to have a baby or how it feels
when she has her menses they cannot
understand what it feels like what a man
wants to have another wife is some
natural that he put only in men and
something natural he only put in women
we can never know what it feels like to
have a baby we could never understand
that and likewise they could never
understand what it feels like for a man
to have the desire to have another wife
and if they say about the issue about
how can you have how can you love them
both you have two parents you love them
both he loved them differently you have
brothers and sisters you love them all
so you're you know love is not something
that just can be contained just by one
person you know you love and your love
is not limited like that and you're
constantly sharing and they love as well
yep danceable which one of my children
do you want me to kill me if I don't
want them which one don't I love and you
love them all and you sure you treat
them fairly
not equally I mean they're not equally
not the same i should say but fairly has
a different personalities and a
different needs they have and likewise
that's the case with marriage yeah we're
going to have to cut out i'm sorry
inshallah God willing we have to
continue on with this series talking
about family talking about divorce and
some of the ways that we can help keep
the family together some of the ways
that we can keep from just doing it the
wrong way and focus and push people to
get educated educated under Dean on this
beautiful way of life way of life of all
the messages of God Islam that complete
submission to the one guy doing his will
not our desires we can continue on in
Charlotte inshallah we got 80 lower
would you thank you sound like my
alaikum Salaam Rock Bluff not too
peaceful I thank you again for tuning in
to another episode of the Dean show you
can go to the Dean show calm sheikh abu
taubah has his own section there so you
can see some of the shows that we've
covered in the past and as we started
with peace we end with peace and we hope
that you can continue to learn about
this beautiful way of life the way of
life of all the message of a god
submitting yourself entirely to the One
God not your desires so in matters of
worship prayer fasting charity
everything's been laid out how to do it
and in marriage the role of the husband
and the wife how to live together in
peace and harmony so you can have
tranquility in a house if we do it God's
Way a laws way we're going to have it
that way but if we run and do it
according to our desires then there's
going to be corruption and there's going
to be so much disunity and we want to
make sure that there's unity and we want
to make sure that we're having happiness
and finding solace within each other but
we got to do things laws way God's Way
the craters way so we can achieve
success in this life and success
definitely in the next and we'll see you
next time here in the D show until then
peace be unto you